in India protests are being held over
the death of a 15 year old student
allegedly beaten by his teacher
demonstrations turned violent in the
state of uttar Pradesh the boy belonged
to the dalit community that are
discriminated against under the Hindu
caste hierarchy the teacher has not been
found and belongs to a community
regarded as upper caste parfney mittal
reports from New Delhi
there is growing anger against castism
and caste-based violence in India last
evening violent protests broke out in a
city in Northern India over the boy's
death the family says that the boy was
beaten by his teacher a few weeks ago
for making a spelling error now the
family has called this a cost-based hate
crime this family is from the lowest
cost in the Hindu caste system the
social hierarchical system this
community is often treated as
Untouchables now untouchability in India
is banned but remains rampant the police
have filed a complaint against the
teacher who they say is absconding you
know this comes as hate crimes like
these have become more common and have
been in the news more often
according to the gov according to
government data about five cost-based
hate crimes take place every hour on
average in the country now India does
have strict and stringent laws against
crimes like these in fact a few years
ago some of these laws were even
strengthened but activists say that
enforcement remains weak we've also seen
members of this community mobilize and
assert their rights increasingly over
the last few years but their efforts
have often been met with more
discrimination and as in incidents like
these more violence
a series of beatings and rapes of
members of India's Dalek Community have
been carried out in recent weeks two
weeks ago the bodies of two Dart teenage
sisters were found hanging from a tree
in the northern uttar Pradesh State
Police suspect they were gang raped and
murdered a week earlier a 15 year old
Donald boy was fined for touching an
idol and Southern Khan ataka State
Village Elders ruled it had turned in
pure they said if the money wasn't paid
the family would be thrown out of the
village and in August a dullet boy died
after being beaten by his teacher in
Rajasthan State he allegedly drank water
from an earthen pot reserved for
teachers from higher castes
well let's bring in Ria Singh now she's
co-founder of the organization dalit
women fight she joins us from New Delhi
thank you so much for being on this
NewsHour for those of us outside India
can you just explain why there is such
hostility and violence towards the Dalek
community
this was basically a given section which
is acceptable until we had it in
Constitution which termed everybody as
equal and also ensured certain extra
entitlements and security to talents who
were Untouchables so this present
incident which has happened with this
young boy in utility issues actually a
reflection of
the entrance caste hatred that uh Abacus
people are dominant cause people have
against
so precisely that Indian constitution
made us as eco-citizens who can now sit
have access to schools and natural
resources and be equal citizens
basically so this
from you know pronouncing this big theme
which is a basic human right came as a
big discount for to dominant cause
people because that was not normal and
now the only way that they could resort
to to stop these entitlements of other
equal citizen that we have got is
through resorting to such brutal crimes
not even when the hatred is so strong
and
so much interested people in that it's
not even leave young children
and they end up being killing them yeah
just a few moments ago I read out a list
of about four or five examples of
attacks in just the last couple of weeks
do you think it's getting worse
yeah I think there is uh no comparison
in terms of when it was better and when
it was worse it is more like that these
cases are being given to come forth like
the community it's when they reached the
police station the police doesn't
register the case they go to the school
the school doesn't listen to it they go
to a local punctuality like in villages
before going to the police station they
may go to the Village head for the
company nobody listens to them so I
think it is through the access of social
media that when they are thrown away or
thrown out from all the other areas
where that we will start to be taken
care of there is also social media or
somebody from the community just puts up
on social media and it's basically
getting more visibility not really that
the cases are rising it's more about the
visibility that we are able to make it
being heard in a large public okay why
do you think uh the death of this 15
year old boy has sparked such a backlash
oh
see one that we've always been seeing is
uh
that in past one ticket there is a
sufficient amount of dollar people who
have entered universities and schools
and we definitely have internal
Communications about these kind of cases
and an alignment that the community will
stand for any of such brutality and
these mobilizations are a result of it's
like a generational
collectivization of people who are aware
of their rights it is not something
which is very spontaneous it happens
every day in different areas in this
country so this is the least I think is
under the protests are the least that we
as a community member are able to do it
so
it's abroad as say it's normal and this
is the minimum that we as community
members uh would stand up for we cannot
push authorities we cannot what more can
we do instead of just raising our voice
so these are seen as protests but we are
collectively raising our voice for
something which is totally totally
unacceptable and really good
so apart from protesting what else can
you do is is that all
I think uh we already have certain
mechanism in place
but it is the willingness and the
acceptance when the authority failed to
accept when we claim that it is coming
from a caste bias
schedules people are turned back their
companions are not registered in the
first place so first is that the
authorities need to accept that when a
victim of a crime turns up to you you
are supposed to register a case and not
send that person back I think when it
comes to that it's
um our complaints are taken very
leniently or they've taken as oh these
people are filing a company laws are
very stringent if you file a complaint
somebody else's life will get spoiled
instead of thinking of protecting our
children our community members the more
connection lies with the cost of the
perpetrator they would want to protect
the perpetrator so I think one that
India
as in a larger form I think they should
accept that there is something like
caste bias along with that cost bias
there are people who are using crime and
violence to justify that class bias or
to derive some pleasure of putting
themselves as a freedom beings and
assassinated beings it only it's only
with this acknowledgment that we can
move ahead people at all levels from
co-ops to judges need to really accept
that yes we live in a country okay it's
2022 but we still have past Prejudice
and our people are also committing
crimes and other people it is only then
when we can take a step ahead okay thank
you so much for your time that is Riya
Singh uh for us in New Delhi